If you have arguments against Islam,
yes, then you're just on the other side
of the aisle because people, you know,
many western scholars, these professors
at universities, really, Bartman and
whatnot, they got they got many secular
arguments against Christianity. Bartman
is not a friend for you and stuff like
that. Bartman is not a friend for you.
You know why? Okay, you mentioned
Bartman, not me. Bartman says it is a
fact of history. It's an historical fact
and he says it as an atheist, agnostic,
that Jesus was killed on the cross. Is
Bartman right?
Okay. So, is he right? Do you know that
there there's sources that say, and I'm
not saying, you know, there's sources
that say that Jesus had a brother, okay,
and Jesus was like a, you know,
basically they put Thomas Ditimus, the
twin. Yeah. Thomas Ditimus. There were
so many other scriptures that the Romans
came down and they said they buried
these scriptures. Then they had the
council of Nika. They said no more of
these scriptures. This is what
Christianity is. And all other people in
the Middle East that had their version
of who Jesus was and what his early life
was because all you have is an account
of three years of his life. Okay, John,
you know you're not listening, right?
Anything else? Okay, John, you're not
listening. You you see you went on a
tangent. You didn't listen. Did you
mention Bartman?
I said he was one of the scholars of
many that I know. Okay. Bartman. I just
mentioned what he believes. You went on
a tangent about Jesus had a brother.
Yeah. Thomas You understand what I'm
saying? Yeah. Can I address it? I'll
address it. Jesus's brother. I know.
Thomas Ditimus the twin. In Syriak
Christianity, the disciple of Jesus, the
Apostle Thomas, was called his twin.
Why? Well, Thomas wasn't from his
family. It seems like they had a
physical resemblance. But put that
aside. You said council of Na. You again
are repeating errors that you picked up
from people. Not even Bartman will tell
you that at the council of Na and 3:25,
I'm giving you the date. In the council
of Nika 3:25,
no one at the council decided what books
of the Bible would be imposed on
Christianity. That was not an issue at
the council of Nika. The council na it
was the I believe it was what I believe
that's wrong. Give me your proof.
I have the historical sources. Give me
your proof. It is a fact by any scholar
even not a Christian. Bartman's not a
Christian. Go contact him.
Say, "Hey, Bart, you're not a
Christian." At the council, I see is
that when they decided the books of the
Bible say, "What are you talking about,
man?" He'll say, "Put down the pipe,
son."
So, you're getting information and
you're paring it and you're embarrassing
yourself for doing so. Now, the other
books that were buried, I'm going to
tell you what those books are. They're
called the Nag Hamari Library that was
for found in 1945.
These gospels, you'll find them written
in the Coptic language. They're from the
second, third, fourth centuries after
Jesus. And these
gospels so-called actually backfire
against you because you know what the
these people believed about Jesus? Do
you know what they believe? They're
called gnostics. That's just the term
scholars give. What do you know what
they believed about Jesus? Exactly. Do
you know what they believe? You're
saying exactly. Exactly what
they believed he was more like a
spiritual leader. They believe he was
God, a divine being from a higher level
of the aons and that he being God either
wasn't truly human. So there was a human
Jesus. Not all of them. Yeah, I know.
But if you let me finish, not all of
them believe that. You let me finish.
Yes. The nagamari. They believe the
divine Christ either appeared as a man
but wasn't truly human or there was a
human Jesus that was indwelt by the
divine Christ. Which of those views
agree with Muhammad?
Which of the views of the Gnostics agree
with Muhammad?
The they thought he was the Messiah.
You're not listening again. The Nag
Hamaradi library,
their documents show that the church
fathers are right when they told us what
they believe. They believe the divine
Christ, he's divine, he is God, from a
higher Aon who either appeared as a man
but wasn't truly human or he indwelt the
human Jesus and left him when the human
Jesus was dying on the cross. Which of
those two views of the Gnostics agree
with Muhammad?
It doesn't matter. Oh, it doesn't matter
now. Okay. Doesn't matter. It doesn't It
doesn't matter because Okay. Doesn't
matter to you. It should matter to you
because your Quran says the true
followers of Jesus were victorious and
Allah empowered them to be victorious
till the day of resurrection. So does it
matter to you who the true followers of
Jesus were? Who were victorious, who won
and remained uppermost till the day of
resurrection?
You don't care. So
what we know is that somebody else got
put in Jesus's place. Where do you know
that from?
From the from Islamic sources. And so a
source that comes over 600 years after
the time of Jesus is more reliable than
documents that come within the first
century, anywhere from 30 to 60 years
after Jesus went to heaven. So a
document that's 30 years after Jesus
went to heaven, is less reliable than
your Quran that comes 600 years later.
Okay, makes sense.
[Music]
Yeah. Okay, buddy. That's fine. Okay.
Hey man, you want you got more questions
or you want to call back some other
time?
All All I'm saying to you is that you
there's some other scriptures out there
that don't agree with what you guys
believe in. Okay. Name them. Name them.
Give me the name. I gave you the Gnostic
Gospels. They not only not agree with
me, they don't agree.
That's what I'm trying to tell you. None
of them go. None of them. They believe
that Jesus was a man, regular man. No.
know the gnostics you're quoting either
thought the human Jesus was when indwelt
by the divine some that even believe
that he was not even born of a virgin.
Okay. I don't believe that. Okay. So
then why are you appealing to them?
Okay. Let's go with you. The Gnostics
that said the Christ is divine. He's God
who appeared as on earth but didn't
become man. They didn't all say that.
Okay. But you're not listening. I'll get
to what they said. Do you agree with
them? Were they right? Those gnostics
that said that that said what? That
there is the divine Christ. He is God
who came to the earth, appeared as a
man, but wasn't actually a man. Do you
agree with them? They're right or they
wrong.
I believe he was a man. Okay. No, I'm
asking, were they right or wrong? I know
what you believe.
Say it again. Okay. One group of
gnostics thought there is Christ who is
a divine being, a god from the higher
level of the aons when he came to earth
appeared as a man but wasn't actually
human. He didn't have an actual physical
body. It just appeared as a body but he
didn't have one. Were they right or
wrong?
Wrong. Okay. The other gnostics believe
there was a human Jesus. Listen to this
carefully. And that divine Christ, that
Christ was different from the human
Jesus. He came and he dwelt Jesus. Then
the human Jesus was nailed on the cross
and the Christ left him. Do you believe
that? Were they right?
They could have been. Oh, so you mean
the Quran is wrong when it says Jesus is
the Christ? Because this group says no,
Jesus is not the Christ. He's a man.
Christ is God that indwelt him and left
him. So then Muhammad is wrong. Nobody
knows for sure. The Quran doesn't go
into detail about it. The Quran says
Jesus is the Messiah. What are you
talking about? Yeah. The Jesus is the
Messiah. This group said he's not.
You're not listening. See, Jad, you're
not listening. This group said Jesus is
not the Messiah. He's a man and the
Messiah is a divine being, a God that
came to dwell in him. But then that
Christ left him when the man Jesus died
and was nailed to the cross. And you're
saying the Quran agrees with this?
The Quran came to correct all the
disputes that they had. So the Quran
says that they disputed amongst
themselves. So they're wrong. Both these
Nazi groups were wrong.
Yeah, they're wrong in different angles
according to Good. So then don't appeal
to them because Okay. Don't appeal to
them because they don't agree with you.
Now, where does the Quran say that's
someone else died in Jesus's place?
That's Sudah 4:157, right?
Okay. Show me where it says that someone
was made to look like Jesus. That's
enough for me. Take it easy. Okay.
Jihad, take care. We'll talk some other
time.
All right. Pray for Jihad. His name is
Jihad.
Jihad. What was it? Jihad Ysef. Pray for
him.